voici un chat
et tiens
[Applaudissements]
tiens
les gens vivent
les gens vivent parmi nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
chance et légendes vivantes est parmi
nous ce soir rich à 100 millions
d'albums vendus dans le monde chrétien
en 60 ans de carrière richard son
concert le 26 à paris le 27 au danemark
et le 28 à bruxelles
richard 71 ans et 200 concerts par an
réd chasse bonsoir halo reach a rejeté
en 1930 en géorgie est ce qui explique
sans doute la chanson georgia on my mind
dans une famille très pauvre père absent
parce qu'il travaillait sur le réseau
ferroviaire et votre mère vous élève
avec la première femme de son mari
comment est ce possible c'est très rare
ça quand même que deux femmes qui ont
été mariées avec le même homme accepte
d'élever un enfant ensemble
ah oui c'est étrange mais j'ai du mal à
le comprendre
j'étais gosse et bien sûr j'ai eu de la
chance
bien sûr ma mère était toujours là plus
personne n'a plus sa carte ans c'était
la chef
mais l'autre dame elle-même et parce que
elle n'avait pas d'enfant et donc je
suis devenu numéro 1 dans sa vie donc
c'était très agréable pour moi ce soit
parce que notre dame
lorsque j'avais des ennuis elle
empêchait ma mère de me frappe c'est
extraordinaire c'est qu'il y en a une
que rightshore s'appelait mama et
l'autre il l'appelait matin voilà
comment ça se passait alors là il dès
l'âge de 3 ans un voisin vous apprend à
jouer du piano des mélodies avec un seul
doigt et c'est comme ça que vous
découvrez la musique c'est tout à fait
ça s'appelait wall est petit
c'était un homme merveilleux parce que
ils devaient savoir qu'il y avait
quelque chose à l'intérieur de monde
parce que il aurait pu facilement dire
éloignez vous de moi petit gamin tu te
bats pas tu suis en train de m'entraîner
mais il a dit non cet enfant eh bien il
a tout arrêté par tendre cette musique
et c'est comme cela que il a commencé à
m'apprendre à jouer avec as de ce doigt
alors à l'âge de 5 ans vous vivez les
charts le premier dame de votre vie
votre frère se noie devant vos yeux dans
un baquet plein d'eau pendant que votre
mère repasse
et comme les vêtements de votre frère
sont gorgés d'eau vous êtes incapable de
le ressortir du baquet est ce que c'est
ce traumatisme qui a commencé à vous
faire perdre la vue je pense pas que
c'était peut-être mon frère c'était
quelque chose peut être ma vue c'était
tout à fait différent c'était pas lille
je pense que le glaucome et est
responsable de la perte tu m'as vu maman
demandé mes frères et bien j'en ai
souffert pendant de nombreuses années
parce que j'en sais sentir spatiale
j'avais l'impression que je récuse
pouvoir le sauver donc il a fallu
longtemps pour que je puisse récupérer
mais
le glaucome et bien c'était responsable
de ma cécité alors sait-on vous avez
définitivement perdu la vue et votre
mère vous y avez préparé parce que ça a
pris un certain nombre de mois et votre
mère vous j'avais préparé et elles vous
disent hey tu es aveugle
tu n'es pas idiot et elle comprend très
bien votre mère que votre salut passe
par votre autonomie et elle vous apprend
pendant toute cette période de perte de
vue elle vous apprend les gestes couvent
à pour un aveugle exact clé tout à fait
à ma mère je sais pas comment elle était
si intelligente si mal dit une si grande
perception mais vous savez tout appris
sur ma mère elle m'a pris elle m'a
préparé pour cette fille je suis tu
viendrais à vers la l année l accent sur
le fait que écoute il faut apprendre
comment survivre tout seul et il m'a
toujours dit qu'il ya tous deux façons
de faire tout il faut trouver simplement
la bonne façon pour toi alors là vous
êtes placé dans un établissement pour
aveugles et s'ouvrent des pensionnaires
et si j'ai une école assez étrange parce
que on sépare dans cette école les
sourds et les aveugles les garçons et
les filles i les blancs et les noirs
alors que tout le monde est aveugle donc
ya pas de raison de séparer les blancs
et les noirs
je croyais bien
tout à fait c'est tout à fait vrai je me
suis posé cette question pendant toute
ma vie et je ne comprends toujours à
cette époque là c'était comme ça c'était
comme ça alors jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans
dans cette école vous étudiez le braille
vous apprenez à écrire le braille à lire
le braille
vous apprenez la musique vous est
influencé par des gens comme art tatum
artichauts mais aussi des gens comme
chopin sibelius mozart alors c'est
l'époque où vous composez vos premiers
morceaux vous créer un orchestre qui
s'appelle de shop boys vous êtes dingues
de musique à cette époque mais autre
drame dans votre vie en 1945 vous avez
15 ans et là votre mère meurt vous êtes
incapable de manger vous êtes incapable
de dormir et vous est même incapable de
pleurer et vous allez voir une vieille
femme qui s'appelle mabec et cette
vieille femme on disait si le paradis
existe elle doit vraiment y aller parce
qu'elles le méritent et mabec vous aide
à ne plus vous sentir coupable de la
mort de votre frère et de la mort de
votre maire de chanteloup sait si frêche
c'est frêche et dames mabec comme vous
dites
eh bien oui tout arranger dans ma vie en
fait c'est qu'elle a fait c'est à elle
m'a fait pleurer c'était pour la
première fois je n'ai pas pu pleurer
après la même chose tout ça c'est sa
mère oui c'est comme ça que vous appelez
et bien est ce que tu penses que c'est
ce qu'elle veut que je fasse
est ce que c'est pour ça que tu as
qu'ils font toujours continué même après
son départ laisse pas ce que tu as
toujours dit qu'à metz alors là vous
sortez de la dépression et à 15 ans vous
quittez cette institution vous commencez
à jouer dans les clubs et c'est une
période difficile pour vous vous mangez
souvent des sardines des haricots secs
du pain période extrêmement difficile
pour vous et en 1947 à l'âge de 17 ans
vous vous installer à seattle et là vous
rencontrez quincy jones et deux ans plus
tard en 1949
vous faites votre premier disque exact
où il fait tout ça c'est vrai on
travaillait dans un club asiatique qui
s'appelle est là et aux îles y avait des
jeux d'argent à l'état gèle y avait un
ticket terao épique un sens du fn a
commencé à écouter mon trio et le vide
émouvoir m'a dit écoute commun est ce
que tu aimerais faire un disque et bien
sûr oui j'étais excité
ah ouais je vais pouvoir faire mon
premier disque je ne connaissais rien
l'aspect je m'en foutais je voulais
simplement faire un disque et en 49
c'est là où j'ai fait mon premier disque
qui s'appelait ses fashion plm voilà et
ce n'est qu'à l'âge de 24 ans 1954
l'année ou pour vous c'est si terrible
serge lama l'année de l'hiver froid de
54 quand votre père arrête de chanter
que vous enregistrez à got a woman
alors il ya ce soir sur le plateau avec
tes oreilles tu charrs un garçon qui
était un réalisateur qui vient de faire
son premier film qui a beaucoup de
succès qui s'appelle yvan attal et yvan
attal a voulu intitulé son premier court
métrage i got you man et il est là ce
soir ils vous regardez vous admire
beaucoup aussi
[Applaudissements]
à
ciao merci m
mais même si ça paraît les 25 26 et le
28 à bruxelles et je remercie jean
pierre gross qui nous a aidés ce soir
pour que richardson avec nous merci
beaucoup c'est un vrai bonheur vous avez
vous avez eue pendant votre carrière à
faire face à elvis presley et ensuite
aux beatles ça pas été facile pour vous
un non non non non non non non non non à
vous savez j'ai toujours appris une
chose d anna précoce reste rester
soi-même en permanence il s'était déjà
fait le vin ils ont beau faire je pense
enfin pour la musique et surtout les
piteuses en particulier j'étais un grand
fan des beatles ont écrit des choses
fabuleuses des beatles vous avez repris
elena reid bo prix hester dead john
lennon vous avez repris imagine en
revanche c'est beaucoup moins - fans
beaucoup moins
fan du rap et vous dit en parlant du rap
inciter au meurtre des flics en
insultant sa mère cette immonde et même
la ségrégation raciale n'a jamais
suscité de telles chansons étaient
[Applaudissements]
fâchés ce qui est malheureux la vie a
toutefois pas ce qu'il faut commencer à
paris les sociétés qui fabriquent des
lycées ce sont ces personnes à qui l'on
s'est produit mais pour moi n'a jamais
fait tu être quelque chose de sale temps
peut-être quelque chose et plein d'amour
est quelque chose que j'ai du mal à voir
comment la musique peut être fait pour
quelqu'un insulte sa mère sa fille les
hêtraies depuis ta [ __ ]
je comprends pas ça à mon avis cela n'a
pas de place dans la musique
un point c'est tout
alors la chance vous avez eu des petits
problèmes avec la drogue
vous avez été arrêté en 1961 et puis
après en 1962 en possession d'héroïne et
vous avez déclaré je me drogue depuis
l'âge de 16 ans ne croyez pas que j'aime
ce genre de saloperie mais j'en ai
besoin
ensuite j'ai fait une cure de
désintoxication et vous avez arrêté la
drogue depuis cette époque
est ce que vous avez vraiment arrêté - a
suivi juste une question intéressante
on est dans la nature parce que je ne
suis pas sûr s'il faut parler bébé est
très spécifique quand vous d'inventer
ces faits a été arrêté quoi if you mean
et si vous dit vous voulez dire qu'on
fume du cannabis
ici tout le monde en film ne vous en
faites pas
eliès mockingbird date n'a pas blâmé
anna est ok a los angeles votre bureau
est un immeuble sans fenêtre et dans à
l'inter de cet immeuble
on doit rien touché parce que vous savez
exactement où chaque chose se trouve
c'est à dire que vous avez un petit peu
la vision au bout des doigts houeillès
aïe aïe j'ai mal conçu
donc c'est vrai se trouvait et bien sûr
j'ai mis tout ça vire l'intérieur
l'intérieur tant que c'est naturellement
au tout ce qu'on veut parce que c'est
donc c'est très facile mais j'ai lâché
paix ce mois pour vivre
alors votre force effectivement c'est
cette vision au bout des doigts et aussi
vous aurez votre wii on vous appelle
bayonne ic ir ce qui veut dire l'oreille
bionique
vous avez l'oreille absolue et vous
dites mes oreilles me 10 99 % de ce que
je dois savoir sur ce qui m'entoure et
c'est pour ça que vous financez des
associations qui s'occupent de d'opérer
les oreilles y est ça ma forme d'avis
j'ai dû est ce que nous faisons c'est
mettre en place des implantations mère
des enfants qui n'ont jamais rien
entendu de leur fille bien merci ray
vous avez une question à poser à red
charles sylvain attal non il faudrait
juste dire à quel point je suis ému de
le voir 2 je trouve que c'est là la
grande classe
[Applaudissements]
à
cette gamme
[Applaudissements]
là
maintenant on est le pire est à venir le
pire est à venir nous allons faire et
minka mieux à tanda
[Applaudissements]
bright chasse que préférez vous en vous
au fait ce que je préfère la fissure
s'est pas fait attendre mais je préfère
la perfection non on peut jamais nerveux
des jeunes arrivent répète jamais enfin
c'est ce que je préfère moi avons pensé
que je voudrais être comme les autres
voilà tout moment la fille voilà qu'est
ce que vous détestez en vous au nom de
la race il ya quelque chose dans la vie
honnêtement je dirais que je déteste
cette chose parce que j'ai appris à
surmonter un mot la plupart des choses
qui pose un problème pour moi
qu'est ce que vous préférez dans la
musique à leur égard j'aime j'aime tous
les types de musique il ya 2 il suffit
d'écouter
vous savez de ne plus pouvoir apprécier
la différence a dit m
la musique je n'ai jamais jamais jamais
rencontré quelqu'un qui n'aime pas ça ce
type de musique au moins music
donc je pense carrément tous les
insulter personne mais je pense que la
musique c'est le plus grand désert
c'est le plus universel dans tous les
cas des causes il y aura besoin de
traduction dans la musique
you don't need transflash les musées
qu'est ce que vous n'aimez pas dans la
musique on a parlé parce que la seule
chose c'est la musique
avec des saloperies mieux mais
j'apprécie tout petit but 6 qui
comportent un sentiment qu'ils aient un
sens encore jeune mais je n'aime pas des
choses sales dans la musique raï chose
qu'elle a été le plus grand moment de
votre vie
homayoun esso mon dieu li na a même cédé
je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir à répondre à
cette question parce que j'ai eu trop de
belles choses dans ma vie je ne pense
pas pouvoir de suite moins de choisir
une chose est voilà la chose la plus
grande peut-être la chose la plus grande
qu'elle est arrivée c'est lorsque j'ai
joué pour la première fois un candidat
le pire moment de votre vie vous savez
dit tout à l'heure quand je dormais à
l'extérieur grâce à dieu que j'habitais
en floride dont je pouvais dormir à
l'extérieur à l'époque où je n'avais
rien à manger où il fallait survivre
peut-être avec l asa l'écossais aigles
de st-isidore cpeti je dirais si vous
pouvez même choisi le pire moment de ma
vie et je dois dire à ce que c'était la
mort de ma mère c'était le moment le
plus dramatique
j'ai eu un problème mais je pense que la
mort de ma mère c'était le pire qu'elle
était richard votre plus belle histoire
d'amour
bon nombre appel à un singe n'en sais
rien
j'étais heureux de faire ce que je fais
et lorsque je le faisais sans voyez ce
que je veux dire vraiment
et votre plus minables histoire d'amour
votre pire histoire d'amour et certaines
agences européennes se séparent
je ne crois pas que j'aie jamais eu
quelque chose de ce genre
ma vie ne s'est pas déroulée comme ça
gréement dernière question est chose que
préférez-vous dans le sexe là je sais
pas si j'ai préférence pour ça que j'ai
tiré tout simplement fait des reds
elle tient prêt
ça paraît
merci merci
beaucoup même si jean pierre gross merci
pour votre aide
ouais merci et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous mettez
un pouce bleus